nicolas sarkozy ha vuelto a ser
condenado a un año de cárcel que podrá
cumplir con el uso de un brazalete
electrónico de esta vez en el caso por
el financiamiento ilegal de su campaña a
la reelección del año 2012 recordemos
que en ese entonces el ex presidente
gastó más del doble permitido por la ley
de partidos políticos y para esconder
este gasto excesivo se utilizó todo un
sistema de facturación falsa entre su
partido la antigua el mp y una agencia
de comunicación que se llamaba pigmalión
y es el nombre justamente de este
proceso la jueza consideró que nicolas
sarkozy tenía la experiencia como ex
candidato para darse cuenta de que
estaba gastando mucho dinero de hecho lo
advirtió a su equipo del riesgo y luego
de que habían pasado los límites de los
gastos pero que no hizo nada al
contrario siguió con más actos y mítines
y que además omitió su responsabilidad
como controlador de los gastos
recordemos que sarkozy fue ya condenado
a un año de cárcel firme y en marzo de
este año en otro proceso conocido como
las escuchas
en francés las penas no se acumulan por
lo tanto cuando se resuelvan las
apelaciones de ambos casos se sabrá
definitivamente a cuánto tiempo de
cárcel se expone el antiguo mandatario